I never hear women talk about all the
things they need to do to qualify for
the man they actually want a man's job
is to be the mountain that a woman's
emotional waves crash into I think in
2023 the majority of people that claim
mental health do not have mental health
I never hear about the difficult things
always what comes naturally it's always
accept who you are whatever you are all
the time and wait for the world to come
to my doorstep there's a sense in the
culture that women are enough you know
we say we're I'm enough this is what you
said you said what's so special about me
most women aren't special
no I'm like seriously what what do women
bring in 2022 that is special nothing do
most women have a cookbook
or do most women really know how to
cater to a man no are most women virgins
on their wedding day no so what do most
women bring in 2022 that is special but
why is it all about what we can offer
why is it always because what we can
break because because when when you're
talking when you're trying to sell a car
if you're trying to get married right
then please I'm not saying that women
are cars it's just an analogy
but but if you're trying to sell a car
you have to study the buyer and figure
out what the buyers want and that's what
men want
it all became like a competition between
men and women between everyone and
because like oh I need to show off that
I know how to do this and I need to show
off ha I need I can do that but better
you know you don't think that if you're
trying to get married you should
demonstrate that you have wife skills of
course yeah like who has them at the end
of the day not everyone not many women
in 2022 no but you know what though have
you ever read the book uh why do men
love bits oh yeah that was written by a
single author that is still singing
Someone and I saw that book in the house
and I just cut it off I was like you are
long that book is on my bedside table
that was my Bible a few years ago like
right next to her astrology set
I've been in a relationship but like nah
like if you're not showing me how you
can protect me and how you can provide
me I'm not cooking you a meal get lost
on a takeaway no why would but why would
you be with that guy in the first place
welfare's but
but you know like for example to one of
my exes once I and he's um it was like a
slightly recent relationship and um I
was like you know I prepared like his
favorite dishes because I know how to
cook because unfortunately my
grandmother taught me how to do it how
do you say unfortunately because then
like you know I know for my friends is
good but like for then someone else
who's not appreciating it like what is
it gonna be good why are you picking
guys that don't appreciate it because
then I found out like later on that he
wasn't really appreciating it like and
and you know like I found out that he
cheated on me and like because I got
messages everywhere of people telling me
because like you know seems like
sometimes people has to come to you and
tell you what they want where like he's
probably making mistakes pause for a
second how did he not appreciate it no
he did because like he was like oh my
God this is one of my favorite dishes
that you can make and I was like all
right so that didn't tell me like what
have you done today and he lied and I
was like so why would you lie to me when
you asking me to be honest to you and
I'm like because you can't handle truth
I can trust me I have I've been learning
so many things and he thought in his
head that I wasn't enough strong enough
to handle that fear but you left them
because of that issue yeah because like
so you were strong enough to handle that
issue because like you know what like um
yeah um I call [__] but why would
she stay women make over
the love with them yeah so if you're
really in love with him you wouldn't
have left them
um well yeah but like you know by the
way cooking's overrated men don't care
about that anymore no I'm not no I'm
gonna talk I have ubereats
but I'll tell you I don't think it's
like people act like it's like some
special thing yeah I think it's it's
like an it's like a normal thing that
would endure you to a man right yeah but
like for example if I cook you a meal
you owe me a relationship now you owe me
like for example like a nice thing to do
for someone right whatever you know what
they say I love you but I love myself
more so that's why I leave yeah and
because
um you know and I had meat and I admit
I'm still in love with that man he's the
love of my life but like but you left
them yeah because I love myself no
because I love my I love myself more did
you leave because he cheated
would you say would you say that's
selfish if valuing him
wouldn't you say that's selfish to love
yourself more no because like you you
need you know like everyone says like
you need to love yourself before you
love someone else everyone doesn't say
that women say that I don't know yeah
single single women say that till that
you need to love yourself before a
relationship but if you want to start a
family what do you have to love more of
the family your kids yeah yeah you're
right the family the kids and so it's
like if you're already just
demonstrating before you're even with a
guy that you need to love yourself more
than the relationship and it's like
because like you know because your kids
are going to be forever if you're in
love with him yeah you should call him
on the shot live I'm just trying to get
around the idea that you said you you
love this guy and he didn't tell you
something he was dishonest to you but
you could handle the truth but you you
fell out over this issue even though you
know you've just shown that he should
have lied to you yeah but like if you
admit something I can deal with that but
if you're telling me no I've been doing
this instead of that and then I know
what you've done like surely now is when
you actually build the trust by showing
you can handle the truth right saying
hey you don't need to lie to me anymore
we can this is where you get to
negotiate and compromise
right
I mean I don't lie for example if
valuing yourself meant like no if
valuing them meant disrespecting
yourself would you still carry on doing
it do you think that's what it is
because we live in a world full of girls
that put their ass and titties on the
internet every day I am the first one if
I'm valuing yeah yeah so what you're
saying is absolute [__] you weren't
in love with that man you value yourself
your sex worker let's call it straight
no but like uh I love you myself I Leave
You for Cheating you're asexual I will
admit I stopped doing it while I was
with him because he asked YouTuber and I
tried too but then I went back to it
because because I can't get enough of it
and I don't mean it to disrespect you
but when I you can't get enough of it oh
yeah no does it work yeah in a
professional sense or like yeah it's
fulfilling literally yeah
every every hole you need to get back
with this guy that guy really changed
another another strand of this though is
is what is perhaps what Justin often
talks about which is that um if he was
genuinely high value he would have been
upfront with you at the beginning
because you're saying that he lied about
it or he he concealed it whereas
actually if he'd have said up front
listen you know you're my main girl but
from my point of view I will be I was
like you know if you were telling me
from the beginning like oh look I want
to do this yeah but and not use my job
against me I could have thought about it
because otherwise it wouldn't even mean
like and you know what like we can be
polyamorous everyone is doing it let's
try
I think maybe that's what we need to
start respecting a little bit more as
opposed to loyalty it's just the honesty
the honesty yeah it's just you know
because I don't yeah and I don't like to
have someone else to comment okay look
at yourself but here's the truth though
because if a man came to you and you
truly loved him and he set you down got
everything out the way and you were
needed me and he looked you dead in the
eyes and said listen I really care about
you obviously I'm gonna see other women
there's no way I'll ever have feelings
for them I want to take care of you
completely I want to be the man that
makes your dreams come true let's go to
the dark side of the moon no I'm gonna
be the rock that your emotional ways
crash into I am there for you I am in
love with you let's have kids I'm gonna
have sex with women every now and then
she that girl's delusional she doesn't
know
and and he tells you the truth instead
of being a coward see the problem is you
don't like a man that's going to be a
coward and lie behind your back because
he's too much of a [__] to tell you the
truth you know the truth you know the
truth from the jump that every man wants
to do it it's the respect of sitting you
down and telling you the truth
furthermore most often when a woman
truly truly loves a man she does not
want to sleep with other men at all it's
not this oh you get to do it I want to
do it too because she's so in love with
the man she just wants to be with a man
so
in that in that way I really respect
what you said because it is true in a
lot of women when a man has the balls to
actually tell the truth will in fact
stay because they know they can go get
with the next guy live his shittier life
and then get lied to from a coward I
think it comes from the idea and this
might be controversial but it's the idea
that
life's not fair this is how it is men or
men I don't know this is if you're going
to be men and men and men that's how
they're going to be so if you if you if
you're man enough to say look this is
this is this is the truth this is what
you're gonna have to deal with I love
you but this is what it is
I would take that any day over well the
issue is it's a Marketplace isn't it you
know and it's very unromantic and it's
very sanitary crude to say but the
reality is that dating sex relationships
it's a big Marketplace out there right
so the guy who is high value who has
options is good he's going to exercise
those options in most cases right now
every guy wants to would like to have
multiple women not every guy's going to
be capable of achieving that so you're
going to get some guys who are sort of
lowered down in the hierarchy right you
could date them or you could marry them
and they would probably be you go to my
trans girl okay one one thing I think
people keep on missing with this is that
maybe you're not really even messing
with the high quality people maybe it's
just a lot of mediocre about good
looking people who have convinced
themselves that they're worthy of the
ultimate commitment and love and
attention from each other when you are
you're all as mediocre as each other
right so if you're dating athletes and
rappers who are known for being
promiscuous they're not particularly men
of high stature in terms of character
and you're in a short skirt an after
party you're not particularly why from
material right then so why why do we
kind of convince ourselves that we don't
need to compromise and work for what we
want because I think men understand that
you have to work to get the the woman
like the the one but I never hear women
talk about all the things they need to
do to qualify for the man they actually
want it seems like you don't want to
compromise he loves me must be faithful
he must have this he must have that he
must be loyal or most of the time they
say it when you're not around there most
of the time they can say it when you're
when a man is not around there we don't
have to explicitly state to you what we
you know that's something we do in
ourselves and with our girls and out of
curiosity what do you think that men
want
me personally
I think men want
an outlet an emotional Outlet
when they come home you know and when
they've had a shitty day on whatever I
think they want an emotional Outlet I
think they want someone that they can
like
it's it's difficult
I need you five things five things that
I think you think
no I'm gonna have you do it and then I'm
gonna have Alex do it so I'm gonna pick
two or two yeah so
an emotional Outlet what else emotional
Outlet
I think they want a mother
I think the one
I do I will go as far instead says
stability I think they do want stability
I I know they do silly things but I do
deep down believe that he wants
stabilities what's what's one skill that
a girl would have to have or like treat
watching yeah for a man that like what
would he value
don't say ironing you know what today's
date I'm just gonna say a bean B's
mother be his mother that's what men
just get rid of this book listen
Okay this is the most delusional [__]
I've ever heard in my life you were
describing a child I think she's
describe
to say to a man that you're going to be
his mother I think it's that where you
see like the modern feminism that ego
coming yeah that like you you look at it
she's definitely because if you want to
play the mother then you must on some
level look at him as your son right
which is a disrespectful to do you date
men that are children no no but that you
just said
no I think I think she's dating Italian
I think that a lot of men do have some
really deep-rooted issues that stem from
the family environment and where they've
grown up and who's been around and if
they've had a father figure if they've
had a mother figure I think a lot of
issues that they deal with in their
present modern day relationships those
stem from that's the type of men you've
dated no I'm not saying that but I'm
just saying I'm asking you from seeing
my girls and how I've seen other peoples
and other people's relationships you've
dated so they don't have those issues so
I'm asking about you in that past yeah
but that's something that I've
recognized like my mum um she's a lawyer
and she deals a lot with like nasty
relationships and stuff so I've learned
how to kind of navigate through that so
why do why do you think you attract
those men
do you know what I'll tell you why I
attract those men because I'm a fixer
that's what type of person I am I like
to fix people and you've got that
motherly you got that motherly Yorkshire
accent as well
don't worry about it so it's it's
there's nothing it's it's just that
you're a fixer I just think I'm a fixer
I naturally like to tend to people and
tend to people's emotions and I like to
know that you're all alright and that's
just naturally who I am if I can't fix
you but if you keep giving me problems
I'll try and fix and fix and fix and fix
and fix and fix and if I can't fix it
can I have an example of a problem
um
let me think let me think
it just you kept saying fix and fix I
thought there was like this would be
easy
well the first problem is coming home
and crying to you in the first [__]
place what the hell what the hell are
you gonna do about it right not cry like
that but I'm an emotional Outlet a man's
job is to be the mountain that a woman's
emotional waves crash into if he needs
you to be strong enough to go to work
the next day you need to find a new man
or find a man in general but then that
leads into toxic masculinity doesn't it
has emotions
okay yeah cool so how about he keeps
them to himself and maybe talks to his
colleagues at work about fixing the
problem not coming home like a little
[__] to his wife if he can't make her
feel safe truly feel safe you think him
coming home and telling you about his
problems at work safe and protected
you're gonna feel safe and protected
he's supposed to be the [__] hero
he's supposed to have charge of the
situation coming home and crying to you
like a little [__] is going to do
nothing but dry your [__] up I'm
telling you right now you're wrong
to his mother I think a man has to be
comfortable enough to be able to tell
them enjoy your cats I'm not saying no
I'm not saying that you don't I'm not
saying that you didn't tell me but I'm
just saying that I want you to know that
you can talk but exactly
but it's a double it's like a
double-edged sword because you also said
that you're mothering him and that you
keep having to fix these problems so why
would he bring the problems to you
that's what you said you said you kept
having to fix the problem and fix and
fix and fix no I'm saying like within me
like if I can't feel like you don't have
a problem and maybe that is the men I
attract I don't know but like I I that's
who I naturally am I'm a fixer like if I
can see a problem I'll just try and try
and chip away at it and chip away until
I get to the root of it and then it
sorted see I I personally I interpret
what you say with like such an undertone
of disrespect because to fix someone you
must think that they are broken on some
level and to think of yourself as their
mother you must think of them as a son I
I feel like I hear a lot of undertones
of like I don't really rate this guy and
he's kind of my project when I look at
him as like something that I kind of add
new bits onto a garage workshop and then
I think women a lot of the time use that
as a defense mechanism because when they
break up they say oh he had all these
issues you know he couldn't do anything
he was always crying XYZ I think if
you're gonna support someone you have to
respect them and if you respect them you
wouldn't you wouldn't say I think an old
school woman wouldn't say oh I'm always
fixing my husband's issues yeah he cries
to me at night I'm definitely his like
mother figure you would never say that
because you respect him as a man if you
were such a high value man then you
wouldn't even have to have those
problems to fix exactly everyone well
everyone has problems everyone's having
problems that's how they picture of
course but then you saying that you
can't come home and like if you came
back to your girl and saying oh babe
this happened this happened you're
automatically a [__] like everybody has
problems yeah but I was saying that
based on what you said because you said
that you kept having to fix these
problems that's what you said no that's
what so so I'm saying based on that why
would a guy bring you his problems if
you you said yourself you don't like
that you keep being a fixer no I'm not
saying that I don't like being a fixer
I'm just saying that's who I know that's
actually I'm like that's the energy I
vibrate is I'm just a fixer like but
that's not even like in relationships
that's like even a friendship my life
that's my friendship like if if I'm
having an argument with one of my girls
and her kind of vibe is like okay I need
to step back and shut myself out of this
I don't work like that I'm like come on
bro we need to try this we need to fix
this I'm going to give you some advice
real quick and I hope you don't take
this disrespectfully I think you should
burn whatever that book why men love
[__] but burn that on a bonfire and
read a book about divine feminine Etc
because I think you have a naturally
strong feminine energy but what's gonna
happen is you're gonna get used up
you're gonna go to the club and give all
these feminine energies to guys who go
to the club every day and run through
girls and after you've finished using
the app you're going to convince
yourself that men are trash man ain't
[__] and that you need to change and
you're gonna adapt more and more toxic
behaviors on until at 28 none of no
trace of the woman the woman right here
who says she's a fixer exists because
you've been used up and disrespected for
about five six years so I would say work
on your strengths and develop that
feminine energy for sure but like I
would say don't put yourself in
situation yeah but like I meant I mean
you've never cried to you about his
problems he's gonna go to someone else
because like trust me I had so many
men's then that they were crying in my
shower and I was like all right what I
what what am I doing now I'm real men
don't cry on prostitute showers either
no they don't they [__] don't bro
they don't okay
you've got a clue and you know them
because like everyone comes from trauma
everyone has trauma I've got trauma she
has trauma she has trauma she has drama
probably he has trauma and you have but
a man but a man has a responsibility I
don't click no I want to say I don't
claim trauma I'm so sick of hearing
about this drama I don't know trauma
trauma's supposed to be coming back from
or that's a trauma supposed to be it's
supposed to be I had a real traumatic
situation not my ex-boyfriend cheated on
me
not my parents weren't around enough and
I have some attachment style that nobody
gives a [__] about because nobody cares
about your problems like it's just I'm
so tired of hearing about this trauma do
you know how do you call it yeah because
like people call it problems I mean
problems but it's not trauma shoes they
used to they used to use the word trauma
when men came back from war for p-test
and now women have claimed the words and
use it for freaking everything
do you agree with that term mental
health is that something
I think there are exceptions but I think
in 2023 the majority of people that
claim mental health do not have mental
health
today on today's day and age a lot of
people do claim it I think that
everybody everybody's depressed
everybody's anxious everyone's this and
I feel like it's just all on the
internet they believe everything they
read
if a lot of people turned off their
phone lived in the real world went
outside spoke to people they would be
100 these girls are on Tick Tock okay I
think dopamine
they convince themselves that they are
depressed anxious
and feminists yeah feminist it's not
mental health it's low IQ
it's low IQ because they're too stupid
to realize that they're getting lied to
nobody here Pearl's dead on if you put
your phone down and had a real life and
how real things going for you mental
health will go out the window wait so
are you relating
with a low IQ I think a lot of the
people that buy into [__]
go ahead like people that buy into the
[__] and they get told that they
have a health problem when really
they're just fat and have a [__] life if
they turn their life around their mental
health problems would likely go away no
I mean bad like someone so say someone
says like yeah I'm dealing with
depression if someone came along and
said that would you relate that then to
low IQ
no I think falling for it and believing
that oh yeah yeah of course but you're
not supporting you're not putting a bad
mental health State and a low IQ you
know I would call that person probably
lazy right because they're depressed
because they have a [__] life
well victimhood has become like the the
you know the currency the currency of
the realm I knew someone that was super
depressed but he was like 300 pounds I'm
like what do you expect right you can't
see your dick I'd be a depressed too
yeah I go cry in her shower if I
couldn't see myself
aside all of that to decide imagine like
you're rich you've got like good money
good friends good family yeah in the
side like you're just happy you portray
your happiness you're like you're
generally happy but just within yourself
you're sad like would you believe that's
Mental Health
no oh no no
lack of character building exercises if
you've been you've been defeated by your
comfort I would challenge you that I
think that's what happens a lot of
people think oh if you just give men
things that they should be happy and if
they're not they're meant things it's
about feeling happy within yourself like
okay let me I get what you're saying I'm
gonna land and I think I think people
miss the fact that a lot of mental
health and and mental fortitude and
self-esteem comes from challenges it
comes from overcoming so when you take
that away from people especially you see
this in affluent kids when you take that
away from people what do you have
literally a kid with money yeah and no
purpose yeah no problem so I agree with
him on IQ I wouldn't even describe it as
low IQ because I think it's how we're
raising people now I think was I grew up
in a village in Nigeria so I come I come
from a place where like silence was my
base yeah in London growing up here you
don't have silence you have a phone from
age eight from age eight you're you're
completely exposed to this internet with
polarizing views and XYZ it's how do you
expect a young person to navigate that
and actually form coherent rational
opinions itself is different from the
rest of the
have their Tick Tock and talk about
right I've got this I've got that I've
got this thing and you know you need to
have a label it's like right what's the
next thing yeah so I think there's
almost like a competition for it now
yeah and I'll tell you what I'd add to
what they both said I challenge you to
do this go find a man that makes a bunch
of money yeah he's in jam up shape yeah
got great style great life great friends
travels and ask him if he's [__] sad
Bond one I'll find one but do you know
what's funny I think happiness and joy
is like two complete different things I
feel like happiness is like a fleeting
um a fleeting feeling that you will feel
when you're doing all these things but
you know you have true Joy when
obstacles can come your way and you
don't travel no more you're maybe not um
having sex with all these people but you
still feel this peace within you and
that's the difference between that joy
and happiness so yeah I think generally
we need to I don't know I think
especially in today's day and age we
need to walk a bit more in our ignorance
we have a problem doing that with
accepting that you know what especially
at my I think a lot of people are
walking and they're ignorance
ignorance is bliss if you really want to
learn and consider that about cheating
huh yeah so yeah
it says the woman with a high bone
this fulfilling stop it
fulfillment and happiness are completely
two different things I think
human and happiness yeah yeah I mean
happiness is a temporary mental state
right fulfillment is a bit more stable
I wanna I wanna get through the rest of
the panel because I think the original
question was was the girl should the
girl have stayed oh yeah
so I want to get YouTube I think you
guys both said leave recently did you
say leave no I will stay for like um
I've been treated with them honestly
like I'm honest to you you honest to me
okay like let's do something else you'll
say okay
me
um no she's she's asking than you
um
to be honest I feel like
because he for example the footballer
situation
um
if you're gonna go into a marriage you
shouldn't be having to cheat so then
it's I would leave because I'm expecting
a man to be within even if he's the he's
the footballer what if he told you up
front
if he told me up front like I'm cheating
yeah I'm going I'm still gone okay
because you cheated on me and that's not
what I wanted from you is it cheating if
he tells you
cheating is the decision
you're so cheating like regardless of
what you've done or whether you're going
to do it or whatever it is
if you have those thoughts you're not
happy with me so well every man see
everyone's got those thoughts I would
bet every dollar in my bank account that
neither one of you would leave Drake
you know but that's just like the
greater myself because why am I letting
a man cheat on me yeah why are you just
flexing on all your girlfriends going on
living in a mansion
no it's not about that because if girls
had happy relationships completely
living normal lives and I was seeing
Drake they'd say Rue yeah you're living
this mad life but he's cheating on you
you don't love exactly it's not real
it's not real well that's why that's why
women keep I like how she I'm sorry I
don't mean that's okay I like how you
let your friends Define your
relationship with your man instead of
thinking for yourself
it's literally what you just said I'm
just saying like that's literally what
you just said I'm just saying as an
example no as an example you literally
just said I I would disregard how I feel
and take in consideration my friend's
opinion I'm dating Drake is that not
true I'm dating it doesn't matter it
does matter it matters how you feel
about the situation
we're going to get divorced in three
years I would feel the com yeah but I
would feel completely the same I'd be
betraying myself
everybody here said they were in a
situationship before so you've done it
it's interesting because in this case
you get more so you get you get
everything paid for okay it and and
you're married and you're married to him
um and he does the same thing that the
guys you you have seen before have done
yeah the opposed to Define you like just
because you've done something before
doesn't mean that you're not gonna like
do that counts with a man I'll tell you
that pass the past tends to repeat
itself so I mean if it's something that
you say you don't want to do like you
don't have to do it anymore you're the
TR you decide yeah but men don't forgive
you for your past of course
but I mean like your past doesn't Define
you in the point of no but I mean like
in the point of
um you just said oh you've all been in a
situationship so like why wouldn't you
be in a situationship with someone that
you know is giving you more money no my
point is it's cap
like it's it's cat because everyone here
has done it that's why I don't believe
it yeah but then you wouldn't be looking
for love in that situation I'm saying
I'm saying in a situationship you guys
got less out of it because I'm sure in a
situationship it's you're usually not
being taken on crazy days you're not but
then you learn from it so you choose
whether you accept it like the same
reason of a man
so I I know and a girl that are in a
relationship but he actively cheats on
her and he tells her lover this is
what's happening
she chooses to accept it and move on at
the end of the day that's her choice she
can't come to me and cry about the
situation because she accepts him she
chooses it she chooses that lifestyle
but if she didn't choose that lifestyle
she wouldn't be with him you don't think
it's a choice by dating a footballer
yeah it is a choice so that was my point
when the question
and the question I'm saying was she was
she wrong to leave or should she have
stayed and I'm saying she picked that
lifestyle by picking a guy that is going
to cheat yeah at the end of the day as
you said maybe all Ballers and all
rappers and all these people maybe they
might not cheat but I said maybe the
majority of them do cheat and do this so
what about them individuals that don't
cheat that are rappers or things you
still have to get to know people right
but it's like this is what women do it's
like you're looking for a lottery ticket
that doesn't exist
like the majority of you it's not it's
not going to be you you're not because
like the magical woman that's gonna
change this guy that has always been
cheated what if Chief Keef doesn't cheat
on me
how come like how what makes like I know
uh some of our opinions differ but like
how come you think like this like what
yeah do you know what I mean like why do
you think like that why why do I think
that cheating is natural demand because
8 000 years ago um 17 women reproduced
for every one man so I think it's
actually really common for um and
natural for them to be non-monogamous
I'm not saying that um every guy is
gonna cheat on you I don't believe that
but what I do believe is that women go
after the men that will cheat and then
they cry about then they cry about it
later and I just don't have a lot of
sympathy like if you're going after the
top 20 percent of that if you're going
after basketball players
um entertainers rappers and you're gonna
cry later that you got cheated on no
surprise oh yeah or even even the top
five percent of men it's like these men
have worked their whole lives to get to
a certain point you weren't with them
when they were broke and now you walk in
and say oh be faith to me why would he
again it's the problem of it's the
problem of looking at it in a dignified
way as opposed to looking at in this
sort of sort of more harsh darwinian
sort of um economic Marketplace kind of
a way which is what it really is where
the people are at the top who have the
more opportunities are gonna act on
those opportunities you know these high
value dudes are going to act on the
opportunities that they have because any
guy would every and this is what we're
saying every guy would want to act out
in that way not every guy has the
opportunity to do so but those are the
top absolutely do and they're gonna
they're gonna utilize that for them and
I'll tell you another thing any goal
will take the opportunity to be of a guy
like that exactly exactly exactly
exactly and another thing that happens
because I see this quite a bit myself in
my inbox yeah is the the average guy
that's coming home every night
when he gets cheated on he gets cheated
on with a guy that's that other dude and
he's sitting there being loyal and being
a good man Etc yeah and and she's
sliding in some footballers inbox yeah
and if he bites and she's foolish enough
to believe it'll be anything more than
just sex then she tried she but she'll
probably just do the sex and
at the same time she would leave him for
that footballer yeah it's ugly it is
ugly and I'm not saying I like it but
it's absolutely true it's the huge
majority but it's not the whole of
females the whole of Mills look I'm not
[__] on women I'm just saying when
that guy gets cheated on by because
women cheat to you yeah no of course and
when they do they're generally not going
Downstream to do it they're going at
least across yeah but mostly they're
going up yeah so I mean it is the harsh
reality that's why when he says
darwinistic it's very Darwin that way
yeah but it's an important message
because nowadays people people idolize
celebrities in such a way that I think a
lot of women don't don't think about
stuff like this really like if I it's
true just hearing you talk right now
even they're thinking for love when
you're going for a man like that like a
lot of like I feel like the woman is not
thinking oh like this is this man's
gonna love me like I need to be loved
you know I think she's thinking I want
money you'd be surprised I'm using I'm
using rappers athletes and Ballers as an
example but I see it with the with girls
going after the same guys at school
or girls going after the same like it
doesn't necessarily mean they have to be
famous but I see girls date the same
guys or go after the same guys all the
time and then cry and whine yeah when
they cheat when it's like yeah you're
getting the same result every time
everybody
[Music]
it's not it's one we're trying to make
amend into something they're not when at
the end of the day most men if they had
women pursuing them like the top
percentage of men do so these are all
like uh there's um athletes have girls
on the side that that will the like the
most beautiful women you have ever seen
nines and tens begging them to have
threesomes you don't think any man like
in 20 years a man is gonna turn that
down or is gonna turn that down every
even a good Godly Man
man he just
that's my point even a man that is Godly
like he's still a man yeah no my issue
is when we go after these men that all
the women want and then were shocked
when they cheat when it's like okay well
why don't you go lower he doesn't have
to make that much money he doesn't have
to be that cute oh well I can't do that
well but do you know what it is
that's something it's so important for a
girl to go through her single season
because I feel like in that season of
just singleness and like reminding
yourself you have to reprogram your mind
of okay I don't I can't go for these
guys anymore and even if you know in
yourself I don't want to go for these
guys anymore any guy that comes to you
that's not like this guy that you've
been going through like going for since
school it's like that ick to you it's
like oh like he's a good man but do you
really want that good man like you know
when girls say he's a good man you're
like oh she don't really like him he's
just good because you know he's cheating
whatever but I said you have to
literally reprogram your mind and say
these are my
I feel like I'm suing the process of it
because like even some people talk to me
now and it's like oh this is a good guy
more and like you know he's not like the
other one by side
do you actually want that how old are
you again if anyone no 20 oh wow yeah
how old did you think I was like 25.
I'll tell you why oh okay okay
um so when did when did you switch this
like thinking like you went to church or
something no no I've been in church but
I was always that I wasn't always like
with God per saying but it wasn't this
is not to do with God
the people that I've been with and um I
just realized no like you you preferred
the toxic ones like you liked them a
little better I think I would really all
like the stage like that yeah a little
face but I feel like it's a young people
thing now if you met a guy if you had to
pick between the good guy that's in your
inbox or this toxic guy you're thinking
of I can see it
you're thinking of someone I don't know
who it is someone someone got you which
is okay every girl's had their heart
broken it's like yeah do you know what
it is so is that even if you wouldn't it
you just have to tell yourself that stay
away distraction but your heart you you
would still want the more toxic one I
gotta reprogram my heart no but but if
we're being honest if we're being honest
that honest honest I'll go for it but in
my I'm protecting my heart still I'll
still have my birds up because I'm like
he's not gonna give you what you want
he's not going to give you love he's
going to be doing all the things that
you don't want and ended you up in that
situation after after like this
relationship or whatever whatever it was
you did you go to church was that like
your outlet
I was going to church regardless no what
I mean is that you seem to have had and
you could correct me if I'm wrong some
spiritual like Journey maybe where you
were praying more or like I don't know
what it was yeah that that's quite a
long story
um to be honest but um
yeah funny enough after a relationship I
did get more like
um spiritual and I started talking to
God more and like started like getting
my amazing it's not spiritual it's like
a church it's Christian it's um no I
don't I don't I don't that's why I don't
call my like I'm I'm Christian like if I
just need to say it easily but I don't
say just Christian because it's I don't
just say Christian because I believe I'm
just a woman of God like I just because
sometimes you can say Christian and it's
such a great area like everyone's
Christian if you go to church if you
listen to your pastor but I believe okay
cool I'll look into my scripture I
actually have a connection with God but
to go back so basically though you're
trying to now reprogram yourself to like
the good guys
um it's not reprogram myself it's not
reprogram to be honest I'm not my mind
right now is not on men like my mind
right now is focusing on myself and when
that person comes I'll know the first
season of singleness
I just want to be single and focus on
myself right now but in the future you
want the good guys in the future I want
the man that's right for me okay okay it
sounded like you said good guys earlier
you said you have to reprogram your
brain so I just to like not like the
people that I was lacking before right
yeah so I'd imagine this is the good
guys right
yeah but not in the yeah
no it's not good guys it's the right man
for me that's it like just that you ever
notice that when women talk about one a
lot of women talk about kind of these
single season and taking time for
themselves it's never any kind of
improvement that benefits the future
partner no for me it is yeah they're
never like it's never like I'm training
I'm trying to develop qualities that my
man was like I'm trying to be the kind
of woman it's always like I'm just
letting myself be me you know because
maybe it's something
I think that's weird Carousel bro let's
call it how it is you know going through
this thing in the season like bro it's
just a bunch of things
you can be about your mind why should
self-healing be about another person
itself
but the point from what she's 21 years
old no
the point of this healing I would
imagine is to become a healthy person
then have a healthy relationship right
yeah but that healthy relationship needs
another person so when you're healing
yourself you're also trying to develop
the quality of feminine the person would
like see men understand this right we
don't go to the gym and just decide I'm
just going to be some gym dude now I
want to do better my job I want to have
a better fashion sense I want to work
and always I want to work on my anger
management might understand this but I
never hear women talk about like the
difficult things to me I Define it as
things that I actually take work like
when you talk about the men you want I
never hear about things that take work
like I'm gonna have to learn how to have
a conversation I'm gonna have to learn
how to support him in a way that still
respects him I never hear about the
difficult thing it's always what comes
naturally it's always accept who you are
whatever you are all the time and wait
for the world to come to my doorstep now
it's true because even in my last
delicious I was realizing I was the one
always making the decisions or like in
like literally all my past relationship
well not much but yeah so I was really I
was the one making decisions and that's
more of like a masculine trait yeah so
what I had to realize was how to have a
conversation in a way that was more
feminine like what you were saying
earlier like if the man was to come with
his problems instead of me saying okay
cool I'm the one that has to fix it and
think oh what's the answer to his
problem more like you know what you got
this like I know you can do it like I
believe in you you can do that and
letting him come up with the answer and
be the man so I'm kind of working on
things like that a bit more on like my
replies and stuff because my automatic
response will be let me heal this man so
I need to get out of that before getting
into another relationship can I ask you
a question yeah have you considered that
finding a man that does not bring his
problems to you and solves them for
himself might be the best life for you
no 100 but I mean if he does come to me
about a problem like he's not coming to
me to fix it he's just saying oh this
happened not a thing where it's like oh
this happened what do I do but if that
this happened but it's like as his woman
he's just knowing he's just venting he's
just saying it but I'm my response
should be you know what you got this
that is fine but it's like if he knows
that from past experiences that the
woman is gonna be fixed he's probably
fixes problem and he's gonna feel pity
for um like she's gonna feel pity for
him she's gonna Wanna Stop but if she if
he knows that I as a woman I'm not going
to feel pity for him he will feel
comfortable to like say it I have a
question do you want to be married
yeah I do do you feel like you were
raised to be a wife
um
no in my household no like I was born in
a household with my mom and my dad but
um and they're married and everything
but I spent more time with my dad so
that's why I feel like I've almost as
like such an independent woman like boss
dating all my relationships I'll be
paying for things because I was more
with my dad than I was look up to him
and be like oh
um I would look at him as my role model
so I'll be like you know I'll pay for
the dates whatever but
um I'm trying to come out of that like
that's part of my healing stage I'm
trying to uh follow-up question yeah
would you be willing and accepting if a
strong man came into your life and
helped build you into a wife I'm not
ready yet that's why I mean no no I'm
saying I hear you're saying
is if he came into your life would you
be accepting of him building you into
the wife that he wanted yeah I
definitely will be like that is what I
feel like this healing is for for that
so I'm ready for that um just
just hands who on the panel wants to be
married
um
feels like they're raised to be a wife
I think it depends on the war was
definitely raised to BR how because
especially with my culture I'm South
American like which country I'm South
American Brazilian all right yeah so I
feel like in my culture there's two
sides there's obviously that the side
that everyone talks about that's not
very good and all of this bad stuff but
then on the other hand I've actually
been raised in Brazil and I've actually
grown up in a strict like Catholic
household my mum's always taught me how
to be a wife like from a young age you
would tell me like oh this is what not
really exactly what you have to do but
this is what I mean you have to show
yeah like the traits that a man would
like like cooking cleaning being
supportive yes yeah bring other women
who okay I never agree with but that's
just my personal choice like obviously
in the broader picture I do see men
bringing other women home but in my
personal choice that was something that
that's something I could never run so I
I have a question for the women that
said
um that they want to be wives
um but they don't feel like they're
raised to be a wife do you guys have
married women around you no no I do no
no yeah I do
rub it in
um anyone yeah no you have okay
um have you guys ever sought to like
seek that out
what in what sense because you want to
be married right that's the outcome you
want so how would you learn how to be
married
you would look to people that are
married yeah yeah yeah
most of the time but yeah like all of
this I don't think about that I don't
really look back at my past
to I don't know to move forward I just
know what I want for myself and I know
that no but I mean if I wanted to be a
pro Vault like I played volleyball right
I was offered a pro contract in the fall
and what did I do to become a pro
volleyball player yeah almost right the
YouTube thing took off but I had to get
coaches yeah yeah to teach me how to
play yeah yeah yeah no I agree with that
and I think that's a problem with um
society today we don't
I don't know I think people like Kevin
Samuels he was important because
especially for me he made me
think about what the type of guys I want
would want from me I never thought about
that before I started listening to him
you know he was the first person to say
hey like it's all good think about what
you want as a woman but what about
thinking about what the type of guys you
want would want from you how do you how
do you learn how do you go about
learning what they want and then
bringing that to the table and I think
that's the problem with
with society today it's all about yeah
it's all about well this is how I am and
you know I need to find someone who can
who can match that but I definitely am
somebody that thinks about what you know
the type of husband I would want would
want from me I I um and I acknowledge
that I don't know everything you know
which is why I don't know when people
are talking I'm very quiet I'm like I'm
the type of person where it's like I'm I
want to learn I want to learn yeah what
do you consult what is your source of
information or whether you where do you
kind of get your knowledge on this it's
not that book
I haven't read that book actually I
don't know
um I think
um I don't know it's just it's just
listening to conversations like this
Kevin Samuels for me was somebody that
really like got me interested in
thinking about this sort of stuff I
don't know I don't know I guess yeah
well there's a huge space online of
self-improvement for men because men
generally recognize you know if the guy
is sitting there and he's not getting
you know the dating life he wants he's
not having the relationships he wants he
recognizes well okay I need to do
something about this the onus is on me
and so then you know they go to the
internet and they find people who are
talking about you know making money or
or going to the gym or you know all of
these different things it's all about
self-improvement I think there's less of
that for women because I mean there is
there is some
um but there's less of it for women
because like surgery yeah plastic
surgery because women are mainly you
know there's a there's a sense in the
culture that women are enough you know
we're so we're I'm enough you know
um that gets said very often doesn't it
and and because women are sort of
pedestalized in mainstream Society the
woman is encouraged to think oh I'm a
princess anyway I'm so I'm I'm
somebody's Queen anyway so I don't need
to do anything and actually really what
we should all be doing is looking at how
we can improve right because I knew that
yeah go on trying to talk no I was just
gonna say like for me I obviously I'd
love to be married like in the future I
don't think you know I I don't know a
girl that wouldn't want to be in a happy
marriage and this like that but I wasn't
raised by oh I was raised in the single
parent household like my mum raised me
and my brother and she's not married she
never got married to my dad and I
couldn't ask for anything more like I
think I have I took some of the best
morals from her and my grandma likes
really really strong influential women
in my life and I would take those things
that I learned from them into my into my
future marriage and then anything added
is about learning and picking up from
other people that are also influential
in your life you know whether that be
friends family who you see on social
media who you see just around I that's
what I think certainly are you saying
you don't think you should seek out
married women for advice or you do I'm
just I'm confused no no like I think it
does help but like I'm just saying the
the process is just about learning if
you haven't had that you know you know
what you know what this sounds like to
me right it sounds like when you ask a
student whether they've done extra
reading on the topic and they're like
you know I saw some Tick Tock videos and
YouTube sure I think like Tim was
talking about some in the corridor I
think you have to actively look to
understand the divine feminine and and
the role of a woman and a wife and how
that can compliment a man I think it
sounds like it's very it sounds like
you're not doing that but if you if you
want to be honest with yourself just say
am I looking out like am I seeking out
that information and really trying to
I'll tell you how a man does it right
I've read three or four books on how to
engage with women because when I was
younger I couldn't I couldn't get down
texting game I had me and my one of my
closest friends in uni our whole
relationship is based on us me learning
how to text now text people get no
response and he would dissect the text
and be like you said too much here this
could have been a simple sentence it was
a compound sentence you you kind of gave
the impression that you're asking for
permission here and I eventually figured
it out I read The Art of Seduction I
read Bank volume one two I wrote all
these books to try and understand women
and I feel like you need to do a similar
thing to understand what the man you
want a high level man would want from a
a woman yeah the problem is Alex when
we're sold these books like why men love
[__] to understand that for the movie
Hitch it's it's like what what quality
book is there to understand man the beam
is Led even hitch doesn't even make
sense so he's this Suave guy he meets a
woman who's like got basic levels of
confidence Falls in leveled down and
gives up his whole life on stability to
chase her it's a it's a movie about ego
it's it's what these women like uh these
women that baby trap athletes think are
like oh I'm gonna change him and then
he's gonna like drop everything in that
that's the real message it's not saying
I had to change I had to meet him
halfway I had to help him feel safe
that's that's not what it's saying
saying you're so cute that top man will
eventually fall for you for no reason
because you're good enough I I do still
think it is a whole person it's like I'm
like the youngest person in this room
I'm 20 you know I'm not looking to get
married next year like the whole thing
is just a journey and it's growth and
it's about personal growth and you know
the answer the answer no is okay
you could just say no yeah no it's like
we give this thing you know I'm not
looking to find a married partner like
I'm 20 do you know what I mean but I'm
just saying but it's like you give this
like word salad instead of just no no
but from someone who doesn't hasn't had
that growing up being in a married
household I'm com I'm happy with what I
got you know I'm I can sit and be
comfortable with that when do you want
to be married by I don't know I don't
have a I don't have it doesn't so 45
okay so you you do have a rough okay so
yeah I'd say so I think okay so you want
to be married by 35. yeah I'd say that
was right well I'm not putting like why
is that mad do you want kids because it
clearly sounds like there's no woman
around you who are saying listen you're
young you're gorgeous this is the time
you set the foundations for who you want
to be it sounds like they're saying just
chill trust me when women get past a
certain age the pool reduces
significantly no absolutely not I
disagree with that like my my mom is so
like you and cross my mum actually so
strong and I think whether that's to do
with her job or just the fact that my
grandma was also a single parent whether
that's to do how old your mom she is 51.
and she has a job yeah she said she has
failed as you will
sorry straight up your mom's lying to
you you want to get married at 35.
you wanna have children no I never said
I'd get married at 35 pill was giving me
an estimate and I just said you said you
said yes no she said 45 and I said No
and then she said 35 and you said yes
that's about right yeah yeah too late
too late I'll marry a 20 year old
instead that's fine right look I'm just
telling you like box wine cats that's
your life no I just I don't know
go to the club
how old is she how old are you I'm 37.
are you married huh do you think single
what do you like to know well I'm just
saying like but I'm not the one with the
problem you're not the same though
they're not delusional you're not this
and I hate that for you because you're a
pretty girl that's really smart and I
hate that you're saying these things
because you could probably be a hell of
a good wife and a good mother you're not
a stupid woman I think you're misled
It's just sad to see I'm married on your
37 years have you been married divorced
have you got kids I listen let me just
say this I have it all I got it all
I'm almost stressing to you like I don't
want to be mean to you almost stressing
to you that this is like it's the wrong
path like waiting that late tell me that
it's a wrong place your path right have
you got your life together
that's funny that a sex worker is going
to ask well listen here lady look my
dear yeah I have my life completely
together there's nothing in my life I
would change
why you're being angry now because I'm
trying because
you're angry about your life my dear
okay
I have a question do you do you think
what did you just saying so listen no I
just want to know like no I I really
because I don't want to be mean to you
or anybody and I apologize if I have I
just simply think that wait until 35 to
get married and finding yourself and
sleeping with a bunch of people is gonna
be bad said we were waiting to think I
literally just said that like what is so
right about your path that makes mine
wrong no it's not me comparing myself to
you it's just me saying damn that's
gonna not be good
because I see it all the time it's not
because I'm not trying to pick on you I
just see these girls they're on
Instagram they got their boobs out and
they're doing all this stuff as well at
the same time like that that's that's
irrelevant right yeah right
what does that matter what are you
saying well you shouldn't be talking
like that then is what are you saying
true or not it can be true you guys hear
it just listen like listen to what he's
saying he actually he actually had he I
probably and I've agreed with them but
almost half of the stuff he's been
saying but I'm saying just listen before
you get triggered listen I'm just simply
saying that likely you're going to want
to have kids in a family long before 35.
that's all I'm saying for sure that's
what I'm saying and in addition and I
don't mean to cut you off I'm sorry
you're going to want a real man not a
man that's going to come home and cry to
you not a man that you have the mother
that would just make you a broken bird
you want a guy that you can look up to
and you want to be the like the leader
in your relationship yeah absolutely
but but the but then the suggestion of
like well I'm not going to learn any of
these skills because I'm only 20. I
think I think the general point is like
if you go to other countries if you know
Ukraine before the the current war and
you know Russia I mean there are women
they're getting married at like 22 23.
oh yeah you know it's societally here
we've got this different idea about it
you know but it's not it's not worldwide